¡Buenos días!
de hecho, no sé que horas son para ti, pero
para mi es de mañana.
Bienvenido a la presentación sobre pendiente
y ordenada al origen de una recta.
En esta presentación no te voy a enseñar
cómo calcular la pendiente y la ordenada,
pero espero que despierte tu intuición
acerca de lo que representa la pendiente y la ordenada al origen en una recta.
Para esto voy a hacer algo distinto a lo que
normalmente hago,
vamos a trabajar con el ejercicio para graficar rectas que se encuentra en el sitio web de Khan Academy.
Espero que con lo que hagamos, darte la intuición
de lo que representan la pendiente
y la ordenada al origen en una recta.
Cuando arranca la aplicación, ésta empieza
con la ecuación de la recta,
"y" igual a "1x" más 1, que es la misma
"y" igual a "x" más 1.
Vemos que pare esta recta
la pendiente es igual a 1.
Si revisas el video de introducción a la
graficación, ahí explicamos porque la pendiente
es el coeficiente de la "x", y aquí puedes
ver que para avance de "x" en 1,
el avance en "y" también es en 1.
También podrías concebir que la pendiente
es elevación sobre avance,
cada que hay una elevación en una unidad,
hay un avance en una unidad.
Elevación significa cuánto cambia para "y",
mientras que avance significa cuánto cambia para "x".
En este caso elevación sobre avance es igual
a 1 y la ordenada al origen,
es donde la recta intersecta el eje "y".
A medida que vayamos cambiando la pendiente
y la ordenada al origen para esta recta,
yo espero que todo esto te quede más claro.
Veamos qué pasa cuando cambia la
pendiente de 1 a 3/2.
3/2 es 1.5, tenemos una recta que es mucho
más inclinada que la anterior.
Seguimos cambiando, si la pendiente es 2,
la recta sigue aumentando su inclinación.
Seguimos avanzando, 5/2 es 2.5.
Seguimos avanzando,
ahora es una pendiente de 3 y así...
podemos ver cómo la inclinación de la recta
va aumentando, regresemos, podemos ver entonces
cómo la recta va perdiendo inclinación,
de hecho, la meta de éste,
podríamos decir juego, es hacer que la recta pase por esos dos puntos azules que se presentan ahí.
A ver, vamos a regresar, este caso es interesante.
¿Qué pasa con la recta "y" es igual a "0x" más 1?
En este caso, como 0 por "x" es 0,
la ecuación es "y" igual a 1.
Y hace sentido, una pendiente de 0, quiere
decir que no hay cambio en "y",
no importa el valor de "x", el valor de "y" va a ser
siempre igual a 1,
por lo cual la ecuación de la recta es "y" igual a 1.
Te he mostrado qué es lo que pasa
con la pendiente,
nota ahora como de izquierda a derecha,
la recta va bajando.
La pendiente ya es negativa, es -1/2 indicando
que la recta baja.
Aquí vemos que cuando la elevación es -1,
el avance es 2.
Es por eso que la pendiente es -1/2.
Y creo ya tienes la idea, que mientras el
valor de la pendiente va aumentando,
la recta tiene una mayor inclinación
o una mayor pendiente,
aunque no me guste usar lo que estamos definiendo en la definición, pero eso lo has podido ver en las gráficas.
Ahora, veamos qué pasa con la ordenada al
origen, esto se pone cada vez más interesante,
¿Qué pasa entonces con la ordenada al origen?
¡Caray!
¿Cómo me pasó eso?
Es extraño, bueno, regresemos,
¿Qué pasa entonces con la ordenada al origen?
Nota ahora, la pendiente es -1, la recta va
bajando pero la intersección con el eje "y"es en 2.
Si aumentamos la ordenada al origen en 1,
entonces la intersección con
el eje "y" va a ser en 3, veámoslo.
No, aquí no, aquí solo incrementó en 1/2,
aquí lo tenemos, la ordenada al origen ya es 3.
Hagamos, otro ejercicio.
Aquí lo tenemos, es... de hecho es la misma
recta, lo único que cambio fue la ubicación
de los dos puntos, de hecho, hagamos eso,
encontremos la ecuación de la recta
que pasa por estos dos puntos.
Veamos, yo creo que tenemos que disminuir
la ordenada al origen... vamos dismunuyendo... ¡ups!
nuevamente no sabía que eso pasaba... vamos
bajando la ordenada al origen... estamos desplazando
hacia abajo la recta... seguimos disminuyendo
esa ordenada al origen...
me parece ahora que necesitamos
incrementar la pendiente,
vamos a incrementar el valor de la pendiente...
lo subimos... creo que ahí ya tenemos la
pendiente adecuada, parece ser que es la misma
pendiente de la recta que pasa por esos puntos.
Entonces, vamos a disminuir
aún más la ordenada al origen...
vamos bajando el valor de la ordenada al origen...
de tal manera que ajuste a los puntos...
y, creo que... ¡ahí está!
Lo hemos logrado, es una recta
con pendiente 7/4 es 1.75,
es mayor que la original de pendiente 1.
Y de hecho lo podíamos calcular  pero lo que quiero
es que tengas la intuición de la pendiente
y la ordenada al origen.
Y la intersección con el eje "y", la ordenada
al origen, para esta recta,
aquí la tenemos, es -13/4.
La podemos ver, ligeramente abajo de -3.
Hagamos otro ejercicio.
Y si quieres, puedes entrar a este módulo
y jugar, tal y como lo estamos haciendo aquí.
Veamos, ahora queremos que la recta pase por
estos dos puntos.
Parece que la pendiente de la recta que tenemos
es mayor, tenemos que disminuirla,
ahí esta, parece que ésta sí es.
7/8, lo cual significa que por cada avance
de 8, tenemos una elevación de 7 y eso lo vamos a poder dibujar en otro modulo que voy a desarrollar.
Aquí lo estoy haciendo un poco al vuelo,
pero lo voy a hacer en otro módulo.
De hecho, cada módulo que hago, lo hago al vuelo.
Una disculpa por eso.
Aunque bueno, tú no estas pagando por eso,
así es que no me debería disculpar, ja.
Me parece que estoy muy distraído.
Movamos entonces la recta hacia arriba, lo
estamos haciendo incrementando la ordenada
al origen, observa que no cambia
la inclinación de la recta,
la estamos desplazando hacia arriba, no estamos modificando la pendiente de la recta,
estamos modificando la ordenada al origen.
Y... ahí lo tenemos, la ecuación de la recta
es 7/8 de "x" más 13/4.
Veamos si se cumple lo que hemos
dicho de la pendiente,
si avanzamos en 8, debemos de elevarnos en 7, veamos.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8,
avanzamos 8 horizontalmente,
y ahora vamos a elevar 7,
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7,
de hecho llegamos al punto exactamente
y estamos de nueva cuenta sobre la recta.
Voy a desarrollar algo para ti, de tal manera
que si te confundes no te decepciones,
hagamos uno más.
Aquí lo tenemos... ok... aquí lo tenemos...
¿Dónde está el otro punto?
Veamos si está hacia la derecha,
¿dónde está el otro punto?
Hay muchos errores, tengo que corregir los
errores de estos programas... ¡aquí lo tenemos!...
aquí tenemos el punto... ya apareció...
Tenemos que encontrar la recta que pasa por
esos dos puntos.
Parece que la pendiente es negativa, no tan
negativa, una pendiente negativa fraccionaria
y la ordenada al origen estaría por acá,
7 y un poquito más, 7 y fracción.
Empecemos disminuyendo la pendiente, se me
hace que va a volver a brincar,
aquí tenemos "y" igual a "0x" más 1, incrementemos la
pendiente, esto se está comportando muy raro...
esta aplicación no la había visto hace mucho
tiempo y por lo visto la desarrollé cuando
mis habilidades de programador
eran más bien limitadas...
Bien, esa pendiente parece que es la adecuada,
movamos la recta hacia arriba... mmm...
vamos a subir la línea... estoy dudando con la
pendiente... no, vamos a ver... vamos a acercarnos...
vamos a acercarnos a ver si es la pendiente
adecuada... ¡ahí está!
lo hemos logrado, ya obtuvimos
la ecuación de la recta.
Teníamos razón, la pendiente es negativa,
podemos ver que la recta va bajando,
pero no lo hace tan abruptamente, la pendiente
es de -1/3 y esto lo podemos ver en nuestra gráfica.
Cuando avanzamos tres, 1, 2, 3, la elevación
disminuye uno... la elevación disminuye uno,
ahí estamos, es por eso que la pendiente
es -/3 y la ordenada al origen es 22/3, esto
esto es 7 1/3, aquí tenemos la ordenada al origen.
La recta intersecta el eje "y" en 1/3 del
camino entre 7 y 8.
Yo creo que esto te ha brindado algo sobre
la intuición de lo que representa la pendiente
y la ordenada al origen en una recta.
Lo que podemos hacer es que tú puedas entrar
directamente a este módulo,
para que puedas por ti mismo jugar con
las rectas como lo hemos hecho.
Voy a desarrollar otros módulos, donde puedas
calcular directamente la pendiente
y la ordenada al origen de las rectas, de tal manera que
sigas ampliando tu intuición sobre esto.
Espero que te haya divertido lo que hemos
estado haciendo.
A mi esto me entusiasmo mucho cuando lo hice
por primera vez, es bastante visual.
¡Pásala bien!